What is the most embarrassing thing that you have messed up in the lab or taken?
I think my biggest mistake was an undergraduate.
When I tried to open a vacuum Desecrator large
glass vessel with a flat glass lid,
the lid was stuck and it had a tap at the top.
And I decided to open this with compressed air. So I attached, compressed that,
switched it on and it worked beautifully. The lid shut up with a loud bang,
but what I didn't realize beforehand, but once the lid got to here,
there was nothing to support it.
So it came down with a huge crash and smashed to bits.
I could have been killed.
On periodic videos. What is your favorite video so far?
I'm a scientist not to journalist once a
journalist, not Brady said that for a journalist.
The favorite story is the one they're working on at the moment.
And once they've done it, it sort of fades into the background.
So it's a bit like that for me. I hope every video when we make it,
it's going to be one of the best.
I think the single video that I think is funniest and which
amuses me most of the time,
I still like is our original video about Hasidim where
at the beginning I say, I mean, nothing about,
should we make something happen? I still like that video quite a lot.
Do you think what molecule you have dealt with that has the most different
elements in it?
I always worked with quite small molecules.
I think there's some organic molecule with selenium in it.
I can't even remember the name. It was yellow.
And I think that had quite a lot of different elements in it,
but quite honestly,
chemists don't count the number of elements in the molecules.
You tend to look at just one or two atoms near the center where the is going to
happen. And the rest is rather light my hair. You're aware about it,
but you ignore it sometimes chemists different, just call it shrubbery.
That's like bushes.
And so you've never count the number of atoms,
but now you've asked probably I'll start nightly counting. Atoms.
What is your favorite element?
This is a question I've been asked several times and I have quite a few
elements that I get quite excited about. There's Xenon,
which has been good to me, iron,
which I've studied the photochemistry of this for a lot.
I liked the element sodium because it's symbol and a
is what my mother called herself as a little girl. She was called inner.
So she abbreviated it to now.
So I get a nice warm feeling whenever I see the symbol,
I suppose at moment, I'm really excited about the element niobium.
I've done very little research with niobium, but this morning,
a PhD students started in my research group and she's going to be
studying chemistry of niobium. So I'm really excited about that.
What molecule do you think is most interesting at the moment?
I think huge number of molecules are interesting.
Carbon dioxide is very interesting because how are we going to deal with so
much carbon dioxide in the world that we're making by burning fuels?
But molecule I think is particularly interesting is nitric oxide,
the L the compound and O which is very
reactive. If you expose it to air,
it reacts with oxygen making clouds of [inaudible] almost
instantaneously, but what's really intriguing about this molecule.
Is that quite recently, and by quite recently,
I mean the last 25 years,
it was certainly discovered that this tiny molecule Eno is absolutely
vital in the function of organisms, particularly ourselves,
because if Ana is released in the bloodstream,
it causes the blood vessels to expand.
And so I've always thought it's extraordinary that this molecule,
that was just the chemical curiosity's suddenly been found to be
really important in controlling the physiology of our body.
What advice would you give to young students hoping to study chemistry in the
future?
That's quite simple.
Enjoy yourself and learn as much chemistry as you can.
You never know which bits are going to be useful. Of course,
a lot of it is always going to be useless,
but it's really that you need to know as much as you can.
One of the really good pieces of advice I was given by one of my friends,
who's a bit older than me. He said that you've got to imagine chemistry,
rather like a landscape. If you're walking with Hills and so on.
And if you want to be really good chemist,
you need to know about the shape of the landscape.
You don't need to know every detail and so on,
but you need to know the rough shape of the landscape so that you know which
direction to go in.
If you want to get to a particular place and therefore the more you can explore
chemistry, the better, how many.
Water bottles are in your collection.
I'm not sure,
but I think it's over 300 and occasionally
boring. One falls down and it gets thrown out.
Sometimes I get a really exciting one and I have to persuade my secretary that
we can add it. I've just been to Senegal in Africa.
I brought two bottles back, but I haven't yet dead bring it into the office.
But I think that plastic water bottles are really quite beautiful.
And if they were really expensive, I think people would quite value them.
No, you go run for those who haven't seen it.
That's just some of the collection. Are you proud of it?
Yes. Sometimes I'm slightly embarrassed, but it's quite fun.
It's ruined my life. Every time somebody gives me a bottle of water.
I start looking at it like a bottle of wine. And so on.
I've even just recently written a scientific paper about two of the boat,
water bottles in this collection.
Oh, that sounds like a video for another day.
Brady and I, and the rest of the periodic video team,
I've got really quite excited because we've reached our 500th video.
When we started out, we were just going to make a periodic table,
119 videos with an introduction and an advert hundred and
20 and two.
And we never dreamed that we'd be gone for so long with so many videos.
And first of all,
I really like to thank all of you who watch our videos,
who send us comments,
who even stopped me or some of my colleagues in the street and tell us how much
you enjoy the videos,
because this is a great reward to us to hear from you.
But I'd also like to say that we shouldn't just be looking back,
looking at what we've done in the past,
because science is always moving forwards.
And I'm really excited about what we can do in the next 500
videos. We've only touched on the number of molecules.
There are there all sorts of molecules, which are crying out for videos,
ammonia.
Some of the element videos are not very good need to be redone.
We have a high-speed camera now,
so we can show you things which none of us have seen
before.
And we really want to keep you thinking about
chemistry and understanding chemically more of what's going on around you in
everyday life.
So I hope you'll keep watching and I look forward to talking to you all and
perhaps many more people as well. When we reach our thousandth video,
won't belong.
Oh, say,
I will say thank you to professor Poliakoff who does so much for these videos
and lots of people write comments saying you seem very kind and very wise and
like a nice guy and, and you are,
and also those people should know when the camera's off professor Poliakoff is
even kinder and nicer. So we're very lucky to have him. Thank you. Thank you.
[Inaudible].